guys you gotta see this video that's
going viral and uh i gotta be honest i
think it's fake i i honestly think this
video is fake
um
it's a video i'm gonna play it for those
that are listening i'll try to explain
it where you see a man in uniform i
gotta be honest like it looks real but i
just can't believe it
there is a man in uniform with a bunch
of afghan security forces doing jumping
jacks and one guy can't figure out how
to do a single jumping jack you you jump
and you clap your hands and you put your
hands down and he's like going like this
and he's shuffling around the the the
military guy he looks like an american
soldier just like
almost gives up
watching this video of these guys
not be able to do jumping jacks the
tweet is just it's from some uh from
some user tweeting to uh jeremy uh
boring we tried to train them i said how
the f is this real what the f were we
doing in afghanistan they're not even
jumping jacks have you seen the video no
they're not they're not doing jumping
jacks like the one guy does like a weird
shuffle and they're it's like i don't i
don't understand you know watching this
guy try to explain to them and just be
completely exasperated
it's it's insane i could not imagine
trying to deal with creating a military
out of people who can't do a jumping
jack
now i don't blame the people of
afghanistan this is not their world they
who who was it was it forest who told us
they believed the americans came to
fight dragons was that forest he didn't
tell me that he might have told you that
i wasn't there on the show no i don't
know i don't know was it i don't
remember who said this someone said
something about there's like a mythology
that some of the the the farmers had
because they didn't know anything about
politics or worldly affairs and so when
this when the troops were coming they
thought it was to like fight dragons in
the mountains or something like that i
mean i mean north korea
has been telling their public for many
years that the rice and whatever food
that the u.s is sending
is to compensate for the war in the 50s
so you know you never know you know you
never know what you know our local
governments tell their people i i just i
saw that video and i'm like
we should have left a long time ago yeah
as soon as someone in command saw that
video they said all right let's uh wrap
it up we're packing in these people
can't do jumping jacks what kind of
conflict are they expecting to win
it was it that's why i was saying before
if the u.s really did or whoever you
know wanted this the
military contractors if you want this to
succeed
we have these photos little girls and
boys going to school
we have the the afghani girls science
team and engineering team and stuff we
have this this is really famous skate
video of a little girl skateboarding in
afghanistan
if you wanted that to survive you would
have to stay in the country for a
hundred years
and you'd have to constantly fight the
taliban
and i think they realized it's just not
possible or it's just an extreme cost
because what would happen is here's what
we see did you see those videos and
photos coming out of afghanistan now
almost as bad as the jumping jack video
military age men
desperately fleeing full speed
hanging on the side of airplanes
horrifying imagery
loading up the c-17
why didn't they want to stay and fight
for
what they had
because there was no social cohesion so
one of the big mistakes i guess the us
and the contractors made is there was no
culture
the only culture that existed was people
who live in afghanistan and then say
what should i do americans like
basically just deferring to them with
the americans gone they're like we don't
know what we have or what we're fighting
for or why there maybe there is no
national
pride the national unity there it's like
just things all over the map um
on a sectarian basis
um
people who are um you know uh shia
muslims or sunni muslims i'm not
many of the countries many of the
countries uh around the world uh
you know were created when was it 70 80
80 years ago based on religion religious
lines more than anything
it's because the
you didn't have any um
would call it a national pride if you
will
you know
what are the values of your country
just because
i live here and someone decided to make
a border there doesn't mean that i
associate with a person
living 10 miles up a story
that's what the people of afghanistan
lacked
and you know the us is losing it too
when we see like the 6019 project and
critical race theory i i saw these
videos i see these people
running and trying to get on airplanes
to leave this country and i'm like why
wouldn't they stay and fight for their
country because they have nothing to
believe in
there's no great story of the evil that
was that they triumphed over there's no
great tale of revolution how the people
chose their will it's just literally the
us came here told us what to do and i'm
going to school and now it's like oh
with the taliban coming back in
i'll just leave
because there's no reason for me to stay
here it's almost like
all america was able to do was to create
a hollow shell of a country or at least
what they thought was a country i guess
there are stories now of uh but but the
challenge is i i mean obviously the
people who joined the taliban do feel
something for afghanistan no right
obviously the muji hadin back in the 80s
who fought back
russia felt for afghanistan
so right there is something there uh you
know sadly it's only the side of
radicalism extremism
but
i think there's something there but on
the other hand there are things lacking
that's what the u.s didn't understand in
this that you needed to give a story you
needed people needed to have a shared
story of the triumph or whatever it is
they were resisting
but it wasn't delivered and i don't know
if it's possible i don't know if it's
possible to instill like a great story
and teach kids i guess the problem is
so after 20 years there should have been
a generation of young men being like i i
believe in this i i learned these things
but they didn't learn any values they
didn't learn any philosophy or ideology
all they learned was yeah yeah in 20
years 20 years is a literal generation
that's the generation you've got 20 year
olds
people are 20 years old today 18 year
olds these are these are fighting age
males
i don't necessarily blame them the us
did a stupid thing but do we like the
taliban no already women are back in
burkas the schools apparently the
reports the little girls are running
running back home they can't go to
school anymore that's horrifying the
thing that's going to be imposed on
these people and i think it's the
important i think the important lesson
here that every american needs to
understand is if you lose social
cohesion if you lose a
a community identity like what it means
to be
an american why you like this country
what you believe in and what you're
willing to stand up for and i think we
are losing that eventually nobody fights
they flee
absolutely i think it comes down to the
fact that you cannot give someone
something and expect them to take as
good of care of it as they would if they
had earned it themselves
this is uh true on the personal level
and i think it's 100 if not even more
true on like the national level so when
you give the afghani people um if you
give the afghani people something and
expect them to take care of it they're
like well i didn't have any part in this
i don't have any investment in this
there's no reason for me to fight for
this i got a better analogy and i'm
walking down the street in chicago
no one will ever give you a free cd
that's not true people do but most
people don't you know why what happens
when a guy's like hey man you want my cd
yeah well not my money after that no
they've people throw in the garbage oh
normally okay
cool man it's a it's a buck and it's
already in your hand you're like they
can't give it to me too right they hand
it to you and then like okay one dollar
the funniest thing is they they still do
this in some places even though i'm a cd
player but the point is ten years ago
because i'm an old man they they nobody
wants to give you free music in fact i
had a lot of people uh in the industry
would say
those guys is exactly why they don't
sell it you don't value it if it's
handed to you you have to give something
and then value what you exchanged
exactly but but uh the u.s did spend a
lot of time to train people you know
gave them a force so to speak they
couldn't do jumping jacks bro
i wanted this video
if these people are like
from an era of really bad food and water
and they just don't have the intellect
i don't think it's food and water i
think it's these are older guys they
look like they're probably in their late
twenties to thirties and
they've never lived in this world like
imagine if if someone came to you right
now ian and said you know they want they
wanted you to be a boxer someone would
be like okay do it like show me your jab
you'd be like yeah do a dance
imagine uh since you're 10 years old i
know how old you are no but let's say
you're 30 and since you're 10 years old
a canada has troops roaming the streets
and the local government is aligned with
canada
it'd be crazy
it would be crazy so then then when
canada leaves like i'm i'm not kind of
this puppet get out of here get lost or
i'm not i'm not i'm not going to be in
there who who are they
it's i think i think we just don't have
a real appreciation of what it means to
have a farm force be there so many years
yeah massive amount of resentment you
can see it in the numbers of the taliban
increasing like they did too if those
are real numbers it shows that no one
respected the afghan government as
legitimate no one did yeah or the u.s
occupation government either no they
they they feared the u.s feared it yeah
and and so you had peace and you had
stability yes stability out of fear but
not not out of people reaching that
conclusion for their country
and and if your local government were to
be
uh in power
because the canadians who are here for
20 years just to make the
that's a funny thought by the way but
again
you know stop a moment and every
intersection is now checkpoint of
canadian soldiers the day they are out
you
have a nice day bye bye and and you
don't want to be on their side you don't
want to be associated
with anyone in the government in fact
the minute the people in the government
they were propped up by canada
here's the canada's leaving i'm i'm out
i'm not here either you guys ever
watched battlestar galactica yeah oh
yeah you know have you ever seen it it's
good there's a uh
i'll just just you know there's a season
where they find a planet and the cylons
you know i'm talking about the cylons
basically enslave the humans i saw the
first season some of the human silence
are robots they enslave the humans some
of the humans are working with the
robots and so after the humans break
free they're like anybody who worked
with them is a traitor
you know imprison them throw them in the
brig or kick them off or whatever
i like using these pop culture
references because people back oh yeah i
remember that episode oh yeah so what do
you think's gonna happen the americans
are leaving so that's what i'm saying if
we think of everything through the prism
of uh you know trump by the republicans
democrats the
the independent you know the independent
thinking people versus the machine
i think it misses the basic you know try
to put yourself in the shoes of a 30
year old afghani who since he
is 10 years old he is he remembers
a farm force sometimes he has
good memories of them because they
played ball handed out candies and then
he remembers his father at the dinner
you know uh cursing away
at the uh at these troops and then these
these troops come in and sometimes they
dare to help it took away a bad guy and
then the next day the bad guy is your
uncle so you probably think he wasn't
the bad guy it's the military is bad
and then when they leave like it's it's
it's a complex relationship thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you